yes what's up this is andrew for
jensensenses.com so i'm here to make a
big update guys on amc on game stuff a
lot of things happened this week some
good things some bad things so let's go
through everything and let's try to see
how this might impact the price action
let's get into it
[Music]
let's start with amc guys so in my last
update i was telling you that we had
this breakout on the downside below the
triangle double bend that was here guys
so this is not a good signal for the
medium term
so i mean
this is kind of expected that we won't
have this big reversal right now we
probably would have some better things
happening
later i'm gonna tell you how long i
think this would take and how low we
might be going before it happens but
first let's quickly have a look at what
happened during the week we closed last
week around 25 then what i was telling
you guys is that we want to see the
price action closing above the 200-day
moving average all right this one
because you know this is an indicator
that is followed by a lot of investors
and whenever we are going below that you
know they just get out of the trade and
if we come above they might get back in
so it's an important indicator and here
when you zoom in on the first time frame
we were having some good good
things happening all right so 31 was the
resistance for the past 10 candles all
right so around four days
and suddenly we had this huge candle
above that level you know this is a
breakout we had a buddhist divergence
just before between uh here
the market the price action was making
lower lows and the rsi and macd were
making higher lows so usually when we
have this kind of signal the market
likes to reverse but here actually guys
we got [ __ ] i'm sorry for my language
but this is what happens when you look
at you know just the news so i'm sure
you guys saw that already but let's
quickly go through the articles that i
have in bloomberg
bam bam bam the first one so basically
adam aaron sold some shares all right he
started to sell some shares
at 3.7
this is what i saw give me a sec
okay so 300 shares that he sold at 28.8
on december 7th all right so
he sold here okay so right on the
resistance i guess adam iron is using
technical analysis as well and then uh
we still had even after that news so i'm
not sure if the market was aware or not
exactly
when he has done that but we still had
this very positive uh reaction from
buyers and then he kept selling shares
uh his associates as well sold some
shares okay so sean goodman sold 18 000
shares so it's not that big you know
it's just a bad signal those guys they
are basically supposed to do everything
they can for amc price to go higher and
you know sending shares is really not a
good signal i mean if you are
the commander on the boat or whatever
you are not getting out all right you
don't let people down behind and this is
what they did so this is really
something that i was not expecting
personally and that here
created this fake out apes were buying
things were doing better and once again
um i was personally thinking that we
would go higher and maybe test the 35 40
area within next week but you know when
this kind of even happens what can
investors do you know a part of selling
this is natural right when the
big guys start to get out you know this
is the phenomenon that we can expect so
whatever the reason this is what
happened and right now it's not looking
great we faked out here above 31 because
once again we had this bullish
divergence this breakout here above 21.
we can also here we could also make here
a trend line a bit like this
so i mean it was looking great and still
we didn't manage to confirm that so
whenever you have a fake out usually
after that you make new loads this is
how things usually happen
so
let's just be prepared prepared for what
what might happen so let me get rid of
that
this one i can keep it
we got rejected we closed above the
200-day moving average but we didn't
confirm we faked out and right now guys
we are to be going to make a new low
which would make sense after once again
this fake out and the levels of support
to me at 24 y24 because you can have a
look at what happened in may and here we
have one reaction so this is not a very
strong consideration if you zoom in a
little bit more
you can see that this low happened very
quickly the consideration was maybe more
around 25 but still 24 is the bottom of
the fourth wave of the preceding move up
so the bottom of the force wave is a
support level so this is the reason why
i believe 24 uh is a support that might
hold so let's see what happens here i
would personally not buy more at 24. i
think that we might go to 21 as well the
reason behind that is so once again here
whenever this kind of things happen it
takes time to repair so if it's take if
it takes time let's go on the weekly
time frame guys
okay and let's try to see the big
picture where are the strong supports
and 24 is a support because just like i
said it's the bottom of the fourth wave
of the preceding move up but it's not a
strong support 21 is a strong support
and you can see in the past even if i go
back to 2014 here it was support here
support in 2018 it was a resistance then
in february 21 it was a resistance as
well so right now it is a support so we
might here see a bullish reaction if we
go there you know quickly so
what i mean is that for example at 24 i
would be waiting
to see some bullish signals just like we
had here but this one you know didn't
work
but if we have some more bullish
divergences so for example if we make a
new low but we can see the momentum is
still going better how is the momentum
right now the daily momentum is going
lower
but on the i mean the macd the rsi is
making for now higher lows so let's see
if we still make higher lows if we go
lower if yes it would be good i mean if
24 holds we're gonna have probably
some time before taking action you know
we might see something like this okay
so i wouldn't go
right away here by this dip because guys
we it can go lower but if we go to 21
right away so it's a sharp move down i
know but unfortunately it can happen
all right we're talking about 20 so not
in one day but maybe in three days you
know this is kind of the worst case
scenario for this coming week and if
this happens here buying the deep makes
more sense we will probably then come
back towards this downward sloping trend
line
where
you know we might see some selling
pressure
but eventually we would probably manage
to get above that and to start to
develop doing uh higher highs and higher
lows for now
this is not the case so
this is what i wanted to show you guys
on amc so once again let me just quickly
repeat what i think might happen we
would probably go to 24 and might maybe
go to 21. once again here let me show
you the new counting that i have guys
because
uh it's not easy to apply elliot wave
theory to amc let's be honest but i'm
still trying to do it i still have some
good information coming from that theory
and here uh the best counseling i have
for now is the wxy correction all right
so w x y correction it means you have
some abcs inside so i can draw it
quickly
abc
a b c and a b c okay and c waves that
develop in five waves a waves as well
but sea waves are usually deeper and
more impulsive so here in this kind of
situation whenever you know
you're not sure about the counting that
is the best one what i usually do is
that i like to start from third waves
because third waves are very impulsive
and they usually go through major levels
so this is the third wave because we
went through this triangle the wave band
around 38
so this is the third wave and here one
two makes sense so we just completed the
fourth and
we have a fifth wave coming so whenever
you have one two three four you guys
know that we can use fib
to uh projections to have some idea
about what the fifth wave might go and
the open 618 is you know the most common
ratio it can be 1.618 as well but on the
downside it doesn't make sense because
as you can see the 1.618 is at zero so
this is not working but the 0.618 is at
21. so i have a double kind of support
at 21 coming from natural support that
is the recent highs and in the past it
was a support and it's the 0.618
percentage projection field projection
ratio compared to one plus three that
we're doing right now so 21 is
unfortunately you know the target that i
would give you guys for this week it's
not a good target i know but after that
things might go much better if we go
there then once again the signal that
things start to go better is whenever we
close above this trend line so we need
to see what will happen before that of
course if the move down is very sharp
and we come back too quickly it might
fake out again but if
we have some nice consolidation here
just before and then we have this move
up
you know
this would look much better so this is
what we would like to see ideally around
24 but if we don't have it around 24
would like to see around 21. and
whenever we have this uh breakout after
this consolidation things would look
much better we would probably come back
quickly to this area around 35 that is
coming from the donald trump controller
that i get connecting the highs off my
triangle that is still valid on the
upside and this is the signal that we
would be waiting for guys so the real
question is so we've just seen how low
we can go i hear some people that say we
can go down to 16 because i guess it
would fill the gap that is here
i mean
i don't think we might go that low
because we've seen what happened this
week guys all right we've seen that when
we came to 25
apes boat all right who was selling it's
adam aaron and his friends right so this
is a [ __ ] uh these things usually uh
don't happen but it happened here what i
mean is that you know we still have
buyers and we can see them we can see
they are active so i mean
what can we say from the fact that those
guys sold because it's interesting to
you know just think about all right they
have information about the company and
they are selling so it means that amc is
probably overvalued all right breaking
news we didn't know that come on we've
not we we have known that for a long
time and
despite the fact that it's overvalued i
mean people don't buy amc because they
think the cinema industry will really
generate a lot of profits in the coming
months or even the coming year they buy
because it's a fight against edge fans
it's a fight against the older
regulations that are not done properly
in the financial industry and this fight
for me will keep happening as long as
those problems are not solved and as
long as there is money in the economy
and the money i mean the injection of
money by you know the federal reserve
and other governments
so as long as this money is here the
same phenomenon might happen this is to
me the sign of a bubble what is
happening in the mean movement is just
to me a big bubble and it's not ready to
burst at all i mean we didn't see the
highs of the bubble yet this is my
conviction this is what i believe and i
think that amc and gamestop are really
the two stocks that will attract the
flows of money because you know
everybody's talking about that so
i think that the same things might
happen again and just that right now we
need some time we need some time
for all this damage to be repaired and
we need some you know good news as well
some catalyzers maybe about the kobe
that would uh you know be handled better
than it is right now
so let's see let's see what happens uh
let me have a look guys quickly at
the synthetic short
so
as you guys know this is a good
indicator of uh the bullishness of the
market whenever you have a lot of
options that are bought on the highest
strikes
this means that you know people really
believe in the fact that mc can go to
crazy levels and
you guys know that we're having this you
know 145 strike on the
gen 22 maturity all right this one
so it's absolutely massive we have
right now around four million shares
total on the strike in which
14
million are coming from
000 times 100
are coming from gen 22 maturity so the
question i'm having is how is it going
to get rolled all right because i don't
think uh this scenario would happen
before 10 22
because of like i just told you guys
this you know takes time for the damage
to be uh fixed and
in the best case scenario all right
we go there
you see it's it's already in march i
mean yeah we can have a squeeze coming
from nowhere but let's be you know a bit
realistic it won't happen that way it
would take some time and for bulls to
gather their strengths so maybe it's
gonna happen in march 22 or even maybe
later but what i'm interested in is to
see how many of those options are going
to get rolled because they create gamma
they create troubles for market makers
and they are for me the sign that things
that the movement is not over so as long
as i will see those crazy options on
those very high strikes which is the
case right now i will still be bullish
and my targets are unchanged i still
believe we can go to the 130 level on
amc
so right now the dtc is at three guys
the two washrooms is 23 percent the
regular shot is 18 so this was october
data oh yes you need to update that up
15.
okay so
slightly less shorts on the 15th of
november data
which is the freshest one but it doesn't
change much there is still a lot of shot
in this market you guys know that and as
long as there is short as long as there
is money as long as the apes movement
is strong
we can see those very crazy moves up and
squeeze happening so now let me go on
game stuff guys bam
all right some gamestop the situation is
a bit different because we are just
at the beginning of the breakout below
the triangular band all right so we are
below the 200-day moving average which
is not good we are below the triangle
lower band which is not good we had bad
results let me show you guys that
so as you guys can see on the 8th of
december the
we were expecting zero minus 0.5
earnings per share and it was minus 1.39
so 168 negative surprise so that's not
good and this drove the price action
lower
oh right then so
let's analyze technically what happened
here uh this was a bit the usual
breakout retest we go lower so as you
guys can see we close the day here on
that day on the 3rd of december we
closed below the strangled lower band
then we retested it and then we went
lower so what can we expect guys let's
be
honest not good things
usually when these triangles are broken
you can expect a correction that is
lasting
or at least one third of uh the period
of the triangle so here the triangle
roughly lasts six months so we can
expect two non-scales two months of ups
and downs but mostly going lower so
something like this okay
this is i think what will happen so i'm
not sure we're gonna go to 118 135 but
we're gonna need to find some fresh
buyers at those lower levels uh this is
what i've been telling you guys in my
previous video this is still holding
unfortunately for now
i mean you know we have those strong
moves down with volume it's not good
technically now like i said guys i i
believe that things will come back to
what they were which is you know a lot
of big money players getting in this
trade because they feel they can make
money and you know i think that this
will keep once again happening as long
as we're in the same environment which
is this free money environment and
for now it's gonna
keep being like that as long as we have
some issues with you know even the kovid
you know the the economy is not ready to
really run by itself uh
at the moment so this money will still
need to be here
and and as long as this money is here
once again i believe that uh the meme
stocks will keep attracting flows even
if right now they're all getting dumped
that's true and we have some major
breakouts on some major new stocks like
amc and gamestop but it will once again
take some time and then things i believe
will get back to what they were let's
analyze guys what we have on gamestop in
terms of
options
okay just a sec then
i'm trying to retrieve the 950 strike
okay
now i think i have it
all right i have it
okay so this is still growing
4.5 million shares on the 950 strike
so let's analyze how much of this 4
million shares are coming from gen 22 or
gen 23 so right now
it's mostly coming from gen 22 you can
see
3.8 million shares here and only 7
million shares uh sorry 740 000 shares
on gen 23. so
let's see once again what happens
whenever this maturity comes closer and
if it's getting road guys it means that
it will take some time but it will
happen this is my conviction
and i'm gonna keep analyzing adoption
markets the technicals everything that
is happening on those stocks and try to
see whenever we finally have this
squeeze
so that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i see you
guys